good evening
this Summit stands out as a landmark in
NATO's long history
we arrived here faced with a more
volatile and dangerous world
and mechanized war in Europe on a scale
not seen since 1945.
an increasing aggression from
authoritarian States challenging our
security in Europe and Beyond
but as we leave the illness we are more
confident and more united than ever and
let me set out three reasons why this is
the case
first we've acted decisively to
strengthen this Alliance agreeing the
most fundamental transformation to
NATO's Readiness since the Cold War
comprehensive warfighting plans to
defend the UK and its allies
scaled up defense production to boost
our stockpiles which will benefit
British industry
and increase defense spending with our
all allies now committed to hitting the
two percent Target
and we did something here in Vilnius
that not long ago seemed impossible
we welcomed Finland to the table as a
NATO member and very soon we'll be doing
the same with Sweden
we are stronger with them by our side
and in time we will be stronger with
Ukraine as a NATO Ally too
and this is my second point
it is now over 500 Days since Russia's
invasion
500 Days
of barbarity
of innocent people being murdered in
their homes
of children being killed adopted and
used as human Shields
I want to pay tribute to the Ukrainian
people into their incredible bravery and
resilience
they're still standing strong and
defined and the counter-offensive is
making progress
in the last few weeks they've taken back
more ground than Russia has taken in the
last year
and we are standing with them and allies
are doubling down in their support
at the Munich security conference in
February I called for long-term security
Arrangements to protect Ukraine break
the cycle of Russian violence and
ultimately help end this war
and today we have delivered
together with our G7 Partners we have
agreed to provide the long-term
bilateral security commitments that
Ukraine needs
these commitments Mark a new high point
in international support for Ukraine
and I want to be clear they are not a
substitute for NATO membership
the summit communique Echoes the UK's
long-held position that Ukraine's future
is in NATO
and we've taken a big step this week
towards bringing Ukraine into the
alliance
together we've shortened their path to
membership removing the need for a
membership action plan and holding the
first meeting of the NATO Ukraine
council with President zielinski sitting
at the table by our side as an equal
and finally I'd like to say a word about
the UK's role here
I was struck once again this week by
just how valued our contribution is
the British people should know that
and they should be proud
we are the leading European contributor
to Nato
we were one of the first to hit the two
percent Target and now we're moving
towards 2.5 percent
we spend more than 20 other NATO
countries combined
but it's about much more than that it's
about our incredible Armed Forces across
land air and sea
we're one of the only countries that
contributes to every NATO emission with
RAF Jets patrolling the Eastern flank
troops on the ground in Estonia and
Poland as part of NATO's enhanced
forward presence and the Royal Navy
including our two aircraft carriers
providing around a quarter of NATO's
Maritime capability
it's about our deep Partnerships
with Japan and Italy we're producing a
sixth generation fighter through our
Global combat air program
and with orcas we're working with
Australia and the US to build some of
the most advanced nuclear-powered
submarines the world has ever known
and it's about leadership
we've led the way on Ukraine moving
first on tanks and long-range missiles
training their troops for the
counter-offensive and just today I've
announced we're providing more
ammunition 70 more combat Vehicles as
well as a new rehabilitation center for
injured Ukrainian veterans
we're moving forward with the combat air
coalition
and the Ukraine in the UK starts
training Ukrainian Pilots next month
and we're using our leadership and
Technology to keep NATO at The Cutting
Edge hosting the European headquarters
at the defense Innovation accelerator in
the UK and holding the first Global
Summit on AI safety later this year
the United Kingdom has been there since
the start of this Alliance
in 1948 in the hope of avoiding another
devastating War
we joined together with a handful of
allies
to pledge that we would come to one
another's defense
that pact was the seed of the North
Atlantic Treaty
75 years later faced with new threats in
Europe NATO is more important than ever
it has proved itself to be the most
successful Alliance in history
and this week we've shown once again
that the UK is at its heart
thank you
we'll take some questions from the media
if I could start with the BBC please
thanks very much prime minister Ben
Wright from the BBC do you agree with
your defense secretary Ben Wallace that
people want to see a bit of gratitude
from Ukraine for the military help
they're getting from the west and closer
to home will government departments have
to make Cuts elsewhere to fund higher
pay Rises for public sector workers
well presidents Lindsay has expressed
his gratitude for what we've done on a
number of occasions and not least in his
incredibly moving address that he made
to Parliament earlier this year and he's
done so again to me as he has done
countless times when I've met him so I
know him his people are incredibly
grateful for the support the UK has
shown the welcome that we've provided to
many Ukrainian families but also the
leadership that we've shown throughout
this conflict as I mentioned often being
the first to to move support forward
whether it was with the provision of
Tanks or indeed long-range weapons and
I'd say he's enormously grateful for
that but people across Ukraine are also
fighting for their lives and freedom
every single day and they're paying a
terrible price for it so I completely
understand
Vladimir's desire to do everything he
can to protect his people and to stop
this war and we will continue to give
him the support that he needs with
regard to public sector pay you know I
said no
what I've said previously is that we'll
be guided by a couple of principles the
first is fans
fairness for our public sector workers
because we want to make sure that
they're rewarded fairly for their hard
work but also fairness for taxpayers who
ultimately have to foot the bill for pay
Rises and the other thing will be guided
by is responsibility I think everyone
knows the economic context that we're in
and we need to make sure that government
decisions particularly when it comes to
not borrowing more are made responsibly
so that we don't fuel inflation make it
worse or loss for longer so those are
the things that will be guided by
fairness and responsibility
can I turn next to Sky News
uh thank you Craig just quickly
following up on Ben Wallace's remarks he
also uh like and uh NATO allies to being
like Amazon uh giving delivery of
um weapons and and protections for the
Ukraine is worried that that might
offend president zielinski who you have
a good relationship with and just
following up on uh president selinski
and your your talks today you talked
clearly about form NATO membership in
the future and once this war is over do
you think that accession will happen
quickly in the way uh the sort of
timeline that it did with Finland and
and now Sweden so how quickly do you see
that membership happening and and you've
had a very successful Summit but back
home it's tough you're 20 plus points
behind in the polls you could face three
by-election defeats next week and all of
your five pledges are in doubt now
you're a prime minister who doesn't like
to promise what he cannot deliver are
you beginning to worry that you have
over promised domestically and that you
can be punished at The Ballot Box not
just next week but in a German election
too thank you
so with regard to Nato membership
actually I think
this Summit has been as I said a very
important moment because you have the
alliance affirming unequivocally that
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO and
Ukraine will become a member of NATO
that's something that the UK has said it
was great that the alliance has echoed
that position and and we saw at this
Summit meaningful progress on that path
towards eventual membership you've seen
the removal of the membership
action plan as the Secretary General
described it that's turned the process
from a two-step process into a one-step
process recognizing what has already
happened you've seen the comprehensive
assistance program be supported and that
will provide support to Ukraine but also
what you've seen is Ukraine sitting
alongside me and other allies in the
first meeting of the NATO Ukraine
Council these are very significant
movements moments along Ukraine's
journey to membership and all of that
was complemented by the Declaration from
the G7 allies to provide long-term
multilateral security guarantees
something that I said I spoke about in
February security conference and I'm
highly confident that very quickly what
you will see is other countries signing
up to that same pledge it won't just be
the G7 it'll be others and if you take
all of that together I think what you've
got is actually president zielinski's
words are probably better than mine to
describe it but he's just described it
as by saying that the outcome of the
Vilnius Summit is a meaningful success
for Ukraine and that he is bringing home
significant security victory
for Ukraine for his country and for its
people those are President zolenski's
words about what this Summit has
achieved for him and for his people and
I'm very proud and everyone should be
very proud that the UK has had a leading
role to play in that outcome and with
regard to your other question then all
I'd say is look I am absolutely later
focused on delivering for the British
people you know their priorities and my
priorities halving inflation because
that's the best way that we can ease the
burden on them and the cost of living
cutting waiting lists because it's wrong
people have to wait as long as they are
currently and about stopping the budgets
because that's about simple fairness as
well as everything else and just most
recently you could see us delivering on
that just yesterday in Parliament
passing some of the toughest legislation
that any government has ever passed when
it comes to tackling that priority
opposed to every turn I'd say by the
labor party but that is this
demonstration of my commitment and my
government's commitment to just
relentlessly focus on the things that
matter to the British people and when I
set those
priorities I didn't do it because it was
easy and you talked about the problems
and delivery I did it because they were
the right things to focus on and I am
ambitious for the country and I'm
ambitious for what I want to achieve for
people so it's right that I say
ambitious priorities and targets and
it's right that we strain every single
to meet them and that's what I'm doing
uh next Bloomberg
I think you can
um prime minister do you think do you
spell see um
Ukraine joining uh exceeding to Nato
within a year of a ceasefire and
secondly on the economy if I may um some
economists according to you to
temporarily raise taxes to take
inflation do you accept that rating
taxes helps the customer inflation and
what's your message tutorial because we
want you to do the opposite I think look
on Ukraine membership in detail I just
wanted to point you back to what I've
just said in detail about how this is
going to work and what the summit
represents as a very significant Moment
On The Journey towards membership and
when conditions allow membership will
happen I think that is very clear from
today's Summit that people's viewers
Ukraine
will and should be a member of NATO
that's uh that's what you've heard loud
and clear coming out of this uh out of
this summer and you've kind of heard or
a certain president zelinski knew about
what the summit has achieved as well
with regard to combating inflation as I
said earlier in my comments on politics
have to pay it's important that
government has a responsible approach to
fiscal policy
in order to complement what the bank of
England is doing on monetary policy
um so that we can halve inflation on its
way back down to its long-term Target
now all the decisions that we make are
going to be guided by that the lots of
the government always has to balance but
I said we've got an upcoming decision on
public sector pay and we'll make sure
that we make that decision by being fair
to everybody both taxpayers and
political workers but also by being
responsible with the public finances and
not needlessly borrowing more because
that will fuel inflation and make the
situation worse and last longer and we
don't want to see that in that success
we're going to stick to the course
because that's the country's number one
priority going back to what bed said and
I'm laser focus on delivering it
uh next to go to the Daily Express
thank you foreign
Security package could actually lead to
World War III is that an assessment
you'd agree with
no I think you know Putin's allies I
think the only person who's responsible
for this conflict is President Putin
President Putin has engaged in an
unprovoked and a legal invasion of
another country violating their
territorial integrity and sovereignty
that is a flagrant breach of
international law in the U.N Charter
those are principles which not just us
but countries around the world think are
important to uphold and you've seen that
in the widespread condemnation in the
United Nations for his actions uh and
you saw it today at Summit and with the
things that were said there so the
person who quickly earned this for is
President Putin probably drawing his
forces recognizing what he's doing is
wrong he's inflicting Untold misery on
millions of people and we are going to
continue to support Ukraine for as long
as it takes to end the suffering and
make sure that they can have their
sovereignty and freedom back because
that's the right thing to do and lastly
if I just go to the site if we've all
time
did and secondly do you think the BBC
presenter should resign
the point about Ben Wallace's uh remarks
and more broadly as I said I think
president zielinsky I know presidents
repeatedly expressed his gratitude uh to
me and to the British people and indeed
other allies uh as well uh he did it
very movingly in Parliament when he was
in the UK earlier this year he continues
to be grateful for our support and our
leadership and the welcome that we've
extended to many Ukrainian families
nothing everyone can see that that's how
um uh and with regard to the BBC I think
as as you'll be aware of the police have
asked the BBC to suspend their inquiry
whilst they do their assessment and
everything is right that we let that
continue as I said I personally
um was was concerned by the allegations
they are serious and it's right that
they are investigated in swiftly and
rigorously I'm glad that that's
happening and we should let that
continue and conclude perfect good
thanks very much everyone